nombre de son groupe pour la première
question la parole est à monsieur jean
pierre vial pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
mais j'ai président monsieur le ministre
lors de la conférence environnementale
de septembre 2012 le chef de l'état
promettait de redresser la filière
photovoltaïque française et au mois de
septembre dernier au terme du débat
national sur la transition énergétique
il annoncé la fin des tarifs d'achat
d'électricité renouvelable je souhaite
vous poser deux questions la première
malgré les crises violentes traversée
par la filière solaire française le
marché mondial continue son
développement et l'industrie française
qui aura perdu plus de 15000 emplois
conserve une vraie capacité au niveau
technologique de premier plan
mais un tel enjeu exige malgré tout un
marché national suffisants ne serait ce
que pour atteindre les objectifs de
votre % d'énergies renouvelables nous ne
sommes qu'à 14 % sur les douze derniers
mois c'est moins de la moitié de 1000
mégawatts fixé comme objectif qui aura
été raccordés et nécessite bien
évidemment un cadre réglementaire clair
est stabilisé
or jamais la filière solaire ne s'est
trouvé devant une telle absence de
lisibilité pour les années à venir
quelles sont monsieur le ministre et
engagements que le gouvernement entend
prendre pour sécuriser la filière
industrielle solaire française par
ailleurs au coeur des enjeux de la
transition énergétique se trouve
l'équilibré électrique défi du mix
énergétique dont l'effacement hier la
loi nome en a fixé les principes et
aujourd'hui la loi brottes en pose les
règles de mise en oeuvre il s'agit d'un
dispositif exemplaire sur le plan
écologique économique et industriel si
une part du gisement est attendu des
particuliers une part tout aussi
importante les des industriels gros
consommateurs pour lesquels le gain
économique peut être vital ce n'est pas
pour rien que l'allemagne s'est dotée
d'un fonds de 190 millions d'euros en
2013 avec une prévision de 320 millions
en 2014 au profit de son industrie
électro intensifs et que la pologne
travaillent actuellement à se doter
d'une capacité de 1000 mégawatts or la
france qui dispose aujourd'hui du cadre
législatif nécessaire et des capacités
disponibles n'a toujours pas afficher
les moyens financiers qui entend
mobiliser alors qu'un grand nombre
d'industries et dans l'atteinte de ces
financements qui leur permettrait de
surcroît d'être des acteurs puissants et
utile de la transition énergétique quels
sont les engagements sur ce point que le
gouvernement entend prendre en faveur de
la filière industrielle française
je remercie je passe la parole à
monsieur
istres philippe martin ministre à
l'écologie développement durable et de
l'énergie oui monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jean-pierre vial je
suis d'abord très heureux d'être passé
au crible par le sénat pour la première
fois de ma vie
la filière photovoltaïque française se
trouve dans une situation complexe elle
a subi les instabilité réglementaire
passé qui ont conduit à une bulle
spéculative n'aurait pas là l'impudeur
de vous rappeler sous quelle majorité
cette bulle a éclaté un nouveau cadre
été mis en place début 2013 j'ai
notamment annoncé le travail sur un
cahier des charges pour le lancement
début 2014 un nouvel appel pour les
installations de plus de 250 kilowatts
ses modalités de soutien se poursuivront
pour maintenir le rythme de déploiement
à l'échelle métropolitaine
il faut pouvoir maintenir une cadence
raisonnable afin de s'inscrire dans la
durée à l'avenir le soutien au
photovoltaïque intégrera aussi les
évolutions des modalités de soutien est
le résultat des travaux de prospective
sur ce que sera le marché photovoltaïque
dans quelques années c'est essentiel si
l'on veut faire les bons choix
structurelles il faut aussi prendre en
compte les contraintes financières car
le développement des er vous le savez ce
sont les commentaires les consommateurs
qui le supportent ensemble nous devons
donc viser à l'optimalité économique du
système vous mettez en avant le fait
qu'en 2013 nous n'allons pas atteindre
les 1000 mégawatts et vous avez raison
mais c'est la conséquence directe de la
bulle spéculative sur le photovoltaïque
en effet les projets photovoltaïques met
en moyenne 12 à 18 mois pour se
raccorder jusqu'à 24 mois en moyenne
pour les grandes installations ainsi les
projets raccordé au second trimestre de
2013 sont entrés en file d'attende
pendant le moratoire
les mesures d'urgence prises par le
gouvernement en début de cette année se
traduiront dans les raccordements à
partir de 2014 mais d'ores et déjà je
puis vous dire que nous relevons une
certaine reprise avec une augmentation
de plus de 100% des raccordements au
troisième trimestre de 2013 par rapport
au trimestre précédent
concernant votre seconde question la
seconde partie les dispositifs
d'effacement le cadre établi notamment
dans le cadre de la loi brottes que
votre groupe n'a malheureusement pas
soutenu
rt travaille par ailleurs à la
conception de nouveaux produits
innovants valorisables par les
industriels grâce à tous ces dispositifs
les industriels deviennent de plus en
plus acteurs de leur consommation d
entreprise se spécialise dans le domaine
de l'effacement afin de faire baisser
les factures d'électricité des
industriels en 2013 c'est plus de 1200
mégawatts qui sont actionnable selon
energy pool que vous connaissez bien
pour les industriels cela pourra se
traduire par des baisses significatives
de factures mon cabinet travaille
étroitement avec les effaceurs pour
veiller à ce que les textes
réglementaires permettent le
développement effectif de l'effacement
car entre effacement et production je
préfère bien sur l'effacement surtout si
cher monsieur le ministre deux minutes
pour la réponse c'est la première
question crible il nous sera beaucoup
pardonné mais nous serons vigilants sur
les suivantes la parole est à monsieur
vial pour la réplique oui monsieur mais
nice j'ai bien sûr la première question
entendu votre réponse
également les engagements sur les
objectifs que vous avez rappelé puis je
citer un exemple qui est quand même une
référence qui sera d'ailleurs je crois
un test pour tous c'est la situation de
l'entreprise bosch à vénissieux sur
lequel très sincèrement je sais que
beaucoup d'opérateurs beaucoup de grands
cabinets
manifeste une position très réservé je
pense que c'est un bon dossier sur
lequel tester cette filière enfin sur le
deuxième point j'ai noté effectivement
là aussi votre intérêt pour l'effacement
je me permets de citer un exemple
d'actualité c'était la reprise durant
cet été de groupe aluminium rio tinto à
saint-jean-de-maurienne qui a été repris
par un groupe allemand trimestre dont le
modèle a justement montrer la pertinence
qu'il avait de la bonne utilisation de
l'énergie et notamment de ce dispositif
d'effacement
merci